imagine the government has this
extraordinarily powerful digital
microscope and with this microscope they
get to go in and look at your life from
the inside out over many years what will
they find out that's what happened to me
it wasn't it wasn't unusual to see two
FBI cars parked down at the end of one
or two cars unmarked parked at the end
of my street they later told me in very
antiseptic language we knew when you
left in the morning we knew when you
arrived we knew restart when you shopped
we knew everywhere you went mr. Drake
the many people who used to work with me
we're themselves interrogated by virtue
of their association we're told in no
uncertain terms formally if you have any
contact with mr. Drake and any manner
whatsoever
you jeopardize your ability to remain
employed by us think twice before you
reach out to him and we'll be watching
in the Constitution in the priam says we
the people in order for our perfect
union didn't say we the state didn't say
we the National Security Agency didn't
say me the president says we the people